elle alors vous n'échapperez pas ce soir
jean pierre cassel à quelques questions
de fond
on va vous faire une hardy view
quand vous regardez le nahd 1 à glace
vous dites quoi je trouve que lesdits
matin je me trouve assez en forme et
d'autres pas du tout ouais vous auriez
aimé ressembler à qui quand vous étiez
petit j'ai pas je suis jamais posé la
question je j'avais envie de l'habitat y
croient ils ont deux filles
j'ai envie de faire de faire tout gt gt
boulimique jeu j'ai fait mon ce métier
parce que je j'ai adoré daniel gélin
gérard philipe fred astaire raimu haribo
enfin je veux dire que j'ai pas voulu
ressembler à quelqu'un je voulais avoir
la possibilité de me multiplier et
d'être tout et tout et tout le monde
quoi vous avez pleuré quand pour la
dernière fois je pleure pas mal moi je
plonge et à cga larme facile je pleure
je pars je trouve que je te connais tu
entouré de choses tellement monstrueuse
que je crois qu'il est difficile de ne
pas pleurer quelques fois sur ce que
nous représentons nous les offre vous
diriez quoi de plus négatif sur vous
que je manque de jeu peut-être pas au
bout des choses que je me reproche
souvent de ne pas aller au bout des
choix sur votre carrière par exemple
vous pensez que vous auriez pu faire une
plus grande carrière
en fait j'ai réussi ce que je voulais
depuis le départ inconsciemment c'est à
dire faire ce métier en m'amusant
toujours en gardant le l'envi le faire
et en rencontrant le plus de monde
possible qui me passionne
voilà si si votre vie était à refaire
qu'est-ce que vous ne feriez pas de la
même façon trop mon dieu je sais pas je
vous regrettez rien en fait
non non non non je vous dois t'on rien
je les jours doit être que ça se termine
un jour si aujourd'hui qui avez vous le
plus envie d'épater mes enfants ouais
les enfants ma femme
enfin les gens que j'aime j'adore quand
balkans gelé quand je les ai pas tant
commente l'adresse à quai la dernière
chose que vous faites ce soir avant de
vous coucher
j'essaye un petit pack claquettes sur la
moquette pour voir s'ils me rappelle
toujours c'est vrai alors oui oui mais
c'est bien gentil rouge le champ voisin
on apprend bien quand on sent bien le
jeu au sol et qu'est ce que la vie vous
a appris mais on apprend à vivre tout
simplement
elle vous apprend à vivre est-ce que
vous avez une meilleure opinion nouveau
aujourd'hui qu'à l'âge de 20 ans oui
nettement nettement
vous avez menti là durant cette
interview je ne crois pas vous regretter
d'être venu
non
jean pierre cassel et les amours ses
coûts et ses stocks et la meilleure
pièce de théâtre à la folie pas du tout
tous les soirs vocal de l'atelier
charles dullin